so now we have the last talk of the
entire workshop so like you know it's
always good to end workshop on that
optimistic note just when we think we
have solved all the problems in fairness
you know Constantine is gonna tell us
you know the limits of fairness is such
as even more problems for us to solve
thanks Steven so thank you all for for
making the time to come and stick around
at the end of an intense few days I
really appreciate it and to Nicole and
Moni the other organizers as well as
Steven for graciously allowing me to
give this talk which will probably be
one of the odder closing talks you'll
hear because I think it's probably gonna
have a different flavor from for most of
the rest of workshop and thanks also of
course to to Shafi Peter Kristen and
everyone at Simons
for having me here I've been lucky in
life in many ways and being able to be
here at Simon's has been only the latest
privilege so you you won't think me too
ungracious to take advantage of your
still being here at 4 p.m. to sort of
venture a line of critique of a lot of
the work in this workshop I'm very glad
to debate any of this if you feel
there's a specific point you want to
take up with me
by all means interrupt me if it's a more
global critique of you don't know what
the hell you're talking about
I welcome that also but keep it to the
end probably so I think there's a lot of
work being done here that we've heard
about over the last few days by very
smart and very well-intentioned people
and yet I think there are important
features of the ways in which algorithms
shape social reality that I think are
being neglected by this group
furthermore I think the ways in which
many of you reify fairness actively take
us further away from the goal of an
equitable society built on a foundation
of democratic commitment in which the
human spirit can flourish I think half
of you will think that I'm not
understanding the underlying technical
achievements half will think I'm
oblivious to the real world and very
real challenges that you're trying to
address and half will think I just can't
add but I hope that I might soy some of
you to look at these questions a little
bit differently and that all of you too
will take this commentary in the spirit
of respectful dissent in which its
intended I suspect many of you are well
aware of the issues all raised but I
think we disagree about just how serious
they are
I want to start off with an example that
will give you a sense for the flavor of
my concerns which will convince many of
you that those concerns are completely
frivolous let's think back one year to
August 2018
that was when google introduced
algorithmically generated automatic
responses to emails not only did they
introduce the option but they made it
for a time impossible to turn off they
didn't see it remotely problematic that
a machine should tell people what to say
efficiency is so obviously a paramount
virtue that everything else authenticity
depth of feeling engagement with another
person could be shunted aside the
obvious argument that it's easy to
ignore Google's suggestions in Gmail for
autocomplete of sounds good or see you
tomorrow but it's not so easy they're
making a statement about what is and
isn't socially acceptable for algorithms
to do and I find that statement
profoundly disturbing I sent a fairly
long email to a friend recently and her
equally long reply she mentioned that
Google had tried to prompt her to reply
with one of these three words Wow
beautiful cool what if someone were to
write you and tell you that a mutual
acquaintance has died is it morally
acceptable to click on an
algorithmically generated reply so sorry
to hear that if you're really on the
ball with new technologies and you have
an AI personal assistant maybe it will
even send flowers on your behalf now
this is a relatively minor example I use
it because it's simple but I think it's
more indicative of a profound set of a
profound set of failures I mention it
both because of its simplicity and
because it's a case in which fairness is
not at all implicated if Google gives us
all equally asinine suggestions for
email replies than it is satisfying the
fairness constraint that similar
individuals are treated similarly it's
one of many examples in which
algorithmically driven decisions might
not have a disparate impact on similar
individuals or similar groups but are
nevertheless deeply problematic I think
Julie Cohen who's a professor at
Georgetown University Law School put
this dilemma better than I can
she said big data is the ultimate
expression of a mode of rationality that
equates information with truth and more
information with more truth and that
denies the possibility that information
processing designed simply to identify
patterns might be systematically infused
with a particular ideology what
professor Cohen said of big data is
equally true of machine learning as you
know better than I do effective training
of machine learning algorithms requires
ever more data and her claims about
equating more information with more
truth also apply to better quote unquote
algorithms what I think has been largely
absent from the discussion over these
last few days not entirely but largely
and also the previous conference in June
is attention to the medium and long term
structural effects of dependence on
algorithmic judgment even if that
algorithmic judgment has been tweaked to
adequately reflect fairness concerns and
I don't intend this remotely as a
defense of the status quo I think all of
the the concerns that you're setting out
to address are very very real ones and
that many aspects of our political and
economic system are functioning very
badly
I think fixing them is difficult I think
the attempt to put in algorithmic
judgments that satisfy fairness
constraints as an attempt to sort of
reach a shortcut to solving some of
these problems and I think that that
that shortcut is is illusory
I think the widespread adoption of
algorithmic judgment whether it's a
guideline or mandatory at best leads you
to local optima to prevent you from
striving towards far superior outcomes I
don't actually think there's a global
optimum that can be attained but I think
it's something that we can strive
towards again this these will sound like
frivolous concerns I think to many of
you who want to get down to how the
algorithms are actually working but I
think it's important to ask what the
effect of algorithmic judgment is on the
human spirit what becomes of a judge if
that judge knows that their experience
will be subordinated to the judgment of
a data-driven algorithm who chooses to
become a judge is it and not only for
the people who are sitting the position
of a judge but for those who are being
judged is it different to be sentenced
to a particular course of action by an
algorithm rather than by a person who
rightly or wrongly takes on the moral
weight of that judgment this is not to
say that I think the judges prosecutors
police or or any of the people who exert
power in society are infallible or
anything close to it but I do think that
algorithmic judgment breaks down trust
as Richard Sennett a philosopher has
written
and he's written that on the next page
that I skipped over
sorry about that only there were a
better technology than paper but bonds
of trust Senate wrote develop informally
in the cracks and crevices of
bureaucracies as people learn on whom
they can depend who needs me is a
question of character which suffers a
radical challenge in modern capitalism
the system radiates indifference it
radiates indifference in the
organization of absence of trust where
there is no reason to be needed and it
does so through re-engineering of
institutions in which people are treated
as disposable such practices obviously
and brutally diminished a sense of
mattering as a person of being necessary
to others and I think that's what
further embrace of algorithmic judgment
is is taking even further than we
already have in in capitalism as it
exists in the early 21st century America
Senate wrote in another of his books he
says the emerging social order militates
against the ideal of craftsmanship that
is learning to do just one thing really
well such commitment can often prove
economically destructive and by
craftsmanship it's both he means both
the craftsmanship of somebody say a
carpenter building an object but also
say the craft of being a better judge of
why some judges are clearly better than
others right but but why strive if your
work as a judge to be the best judge
that you possibly can be if you know
that your judgment is nevertheless going
to be subordinated either partially or
entirely by that of an algorithm and
then we're also caught in a certain
catch-22 because though we want those
algorithms to be legible as was
mentioned you know and talk about the
New Mexico justice system yesterday
which I found very interesting you're in
a catch-22 because if that algorithm is
legible which it should be then it's
simplistic it's far more simplistic than
the judges nuanced judgment on the other
hand if that algorithm is a complicated
black box that a what's the best machine
learning that takes you know deep
learning of a thousand layers of neural
network then we don't know how it works
so you're in you're in this thing where
why do you can't depend on a simple
algorithm because it's more simple than
the experience of somebody who has the
expertise of a lifetime and yet you
can't depend on something complicated
because you don't know how the hell it
works which is fundamentally
anti-democratic I want to take to give
this a more concrete example
and I don't think Cynthia's in the room
unfortunately I'd hoped she would be but
I forgot to double-check with her
because I'm gonna pick on her a little
bit because I think if you're gonna pick
on somebody you should pick pick on the
best exponent of a view that you
disagree with and I respect and admire
Cynthia a great deal so I I'm sure
somebody else can take up the mantle on
her behalf here but I was looking back
to a talk that she gave in this
auditorium in April and she took the
example of a person X working at an
organization called nice news and said
well it's a well defined if difficult to
measure probability that PI of X is the
probability over randomness in X the
person and randomness in the environment
that X will succeed at nice news she
defined success as staying at the
company for at least three years and
having at least one promotion during
that time this is a crazy mathematical
model right and I'm sure that Cynthia is
well aware that this is a simple model
but I just want to underscore the
craziness you have no means within the
model to describe if the years the
person spent working there were happy or
unhappy if X grew better at her craft or
not if X left after two years because
she got a better offer elsewhere or not
and I think this is a recurrent thing
that I think economists are particularly
guilty of but social scientists more
broadly and computer scientists as they
sort of edge into social science that
they rely on oversimplified mathematical
models and it certain times are aware of
that simplification and then when it's
convenient tend to forget about it and I
think that that effect is sort of like
far more pernicious than is then as
generally appreciated within the
community I think many important
questions simply are not amenable to
quantitative analysis and never will be
it doesn't matter if that analysis is
done by sufficient sophisticated machine
learning or by a reductive linear
regression tweaking algorithms to make
them fair is just to put a veneer of
social justice on a shaking piece on a
shaky piece of intellectual furniture
where should my child go to college or
when should my child go to college how
should we punish criminals are charter
schools a good idea sure monopolies be
broken up how should we fund basic
science should we have preschools taking
quantitative answers to these questions
seriously not only risks getting the
answer
but shapes the underlying reality in
ways that are detrimental to our
collective well-being such questions
call for informed judgment that balances
values incentives context and other
factors for many important questions it
is difficult to find disinterested
individuals who can balance those
factors and can be trusted that
difficulty is inherent in social systems
and something that we have to struggle
with it in trying to create a just
society settling these vital questions
on the basis of informed judgment only
appears to be more subjective than using
algorithmic techniques algorithms
relying on quantified data allow policy
makers and social scientists to appear
to be unbiased impartial while
laundering their biases and
preconceptions into the methodology by
which the quantitative metrics are
constructed one of the presenters
yesterday complained for instance the
police might manipulate an algorithmic
system by choosing what charges to bring
against an individual so as to channel
the accused into higher or lower risk
bins I'd contend that this isn't a
problem as such to be solved but a
natural feature of the world we must
have police dimension as a society and
we want to be able to trust those police
as craftspeople
to exercise their judgment and
discretion in a fair way trying to
engineer our way out of this just
generates layer after layer of
bureaucratic complexity and denigrates
the professionalism of the police again
I'm not claiming that those judgments
are infallible or even that they're
correct most of the time just that the
work of improving them is not simple and
that there are no shortcuts to doing so
of course even if you allowed that
algorithmic decisions were
systematically flawed in the recent past
that is no proof that future algorithms
will suffer from the same shortcomings
however it is reasonable to believe that
even if the same basic methodology is
used and more data is gathered the same
problems will continue to arise absent
clear causal understandings which are
not only which are not always possible
you're in a muddle and as one of the
speakers pointed out yesterday machine
learning systems tend to be generally
anti causal I think one of the sort of
intellectual Vogue's that that has come
and gone yes absolutely yes
well if you like one intellectual trend
that has sort of gone out of sort of
popular discussions outside of Santa Fe
perhaps is is sort of chaos theory and
complexity as it was I mean we sort of
like internalized it and and forgotten
about it this sort of like having the
Mandelbrot set beyond the you know the
tie at the top of our minds and and this
idea that many real-world systems
display sensitive dependence on initial
conditions that you can change the input
slightly and radically different outputs
will emerge I think that's a lesson that
as a sort of intellectual society we
sort of learned and partially forgot and
I think it's important to remember that
human social systems whether we're
talking about schools universities the
criminal justice system are complex
systems and that gathering more data and
getting better machine learning learning
algorithms whether you gather twice as
much ten times as much a hundred times
as much data won't change that
fundamental fact and I know that many of
you are aware of the dangers of
overfitting but I think you tend to
underestimate just how serious a problem
it is I think that if we're to
effectively debate public policy
corporate strategy the structure of our
economy we will have to continue to have
debates over principles debates over
which disagreement amongst individuals
with different ideological
presuppositions will continue to believe
that rigorous and I use that in quotes
quantitative judgment can be
systematically substituted for such
debate as Julie Cohen pointed out is
merely assuming that we all accept a
common underlying unstated ideology of
course each alternative to quantitative
judgment is itself susceptible to its
own shortcomings and biases what I think
it's vital is to maintain a plurality of
forms of social judgment the dangers of
algorithmic techniques are not that they
exist but that they crowd out other ways
of understanding the world and of
shaping it for the better I want to take
I was gonna read along there's a book
and this debate has been around for a
while a very good book by Theodore
reporter called trust in numbers from
1996 and I said I think he was very
prescient and he said that you know
faith and objectivity tends to be
associated with political democracy or
at least with systems in which
bureaucratic actors are highly
vulnerable to out
ciders that our he was arguing that our
faith and algorithms derives from a lack
of confidence in our political system
writ large i wanted to give one more
sort of concrete example it was a NBER
working paper that that Cynthia had
cited which is what brought it to my
attention
called human decisions and machine
predictions for from a couple years ago
by you many of you probably know the
authors far better than I do Kleinberg
like Oh Roger let's go [ __ ] love it and
milena thong and they said that you know
crime can be reduced by up to twenty
four point eight percent with no change
in jailing rates based on their
mathematical based on their simulation
and I'm sorry but this is a batshit
crazy statement to make but it's not
twenty four point seven percent or
twenty four point nine percent but a
twenty four pull up to a twenty four
point eight percent reduction in crime
and I don't mean to pick on like they
could have rounded that number up to
twenty five percent and and I think my
point would still hold that the fact
that they didn't feel the need to is to
me betrays a certain sort of
intellectual arrogance in in the
confidence that their model reflects
reality and then that gets laundered
Cynthia in her talk and Cynthia's you
know as an extremely smart person and a
leader in this field says well they
showed this they showed that if you do
what they said crime gets reduced by by
a quarter not their simulation showed
the switch I'm sure she's well aware of
but my point is the way that the
slipperiness of language that gets
translated into well these economists
prove that this is the right thing to do
and I think that's very very dangerous
now you'll notice there's an obvious
weakness in my argument I can't prove
anything that I'm saying maybe they're
right about the 24.8% I can't prove that
it's twenty percent or minus 10 percent
or anything else if the terms of the
debate that we're going to have or that
one must show quantitative empirical
evidence for claims I've already lost
the debate and I think I was gonna have
another mentioned a quote from a Steven
shape and a historian of science who was
talking about how these very same
debates were taking place from the late
medieval period through the seventeenth
century in Europe and what's called the
Scientific Revolution and I guess I'll
mention part of that quote but he says
you know it is when the authority of
longest Amish institution
roads that solutions to such questions
about knowledge come to have special
point and urgency
it has concluded that existing
techniques for securing knowledge are
evidently inadequate and new procedures
are can't canvassed method broadly
construed is the preferred remedy for
problems of intellectual disorder and I
think that that remains true today I
think there's a great intellectual
disorder in in how we are to live
together as human beings in a society
that that is fair and just and where the
individual human can thrive as part of a
community and I think this sort of like
attempt to algorithm-- eyes our way
around these political questions is a
reflection of how unstable we are
politically and that's my two cents
which I hopefully didn't put all of you
to sleep and I'm glad to discuss further
[Applause]
[Music]
we have to cheat we have to oversell our
papers and eventually get convinced and
the journalist is even making it worse
because if they want to help to use they
wanted big successes they don't want to
he'll have a very clear conclusions so
so I think that the culture of academics
it encourages us to chip away to all the
time over seven
and the culture of journalism [ __ ]
pushes this even further is even more
extreme in that respect yeah I think
you're absolutely right
um I think I will say I think some
disciplines are better than others about
this I think economists tend to like I
think journalists are absolutely
culpable as you say but you know you can
look at what is say a very significant
paper in physical chemistry that is like
years of work that has you know a the
title of the paper is relatively
impenetrable and you have to actually
understand something about the subject
say wow this is an important result the
margin was too short no no no we had the
doors open we go quoting number theory
it's also there the title of the paper
that saw the problem and it was
marginalia two-way as a paper some
people are very modest right yes and I
think those pressures I think they're
you know there are in part a consequence
of sort of the corporatization of
academic life of the way that
information flows in society that now
everybody can have a twitter account of
your there's many reasons for it but I
think that what is considered seemly and
unseemly within a discipline the norms
that exist with invisablend differ from
discipline to discipline and I think
economics in particular and I realize
most people in the room are not
economists isn't a particularly
unhealthy state right now in terms of
what is and not what isn't is not
socially acceptable Oh in crisis first
sorry yeah it Steven will be the traffic
cop here thank you very much I think so
one thing
is that I think some of the work from
this community has helped reveal what's
wrong with the movement towards
algorithms including by quantifying
although in many cases were just
rediscovering things from other fields
but quantifying different notions of
fairness and playing with those
definitions but then we also have an
impulse I'm not even sure I should say
we as I haven't actually done in the
academic publishing in this area but I
think the community then says oh and we
can fix it right and I think that second
urge that we can fix it comes from a
couple of things one is the desire to do
fun math problems which is what many of
us do day to day and so when we see a
social challenge there is an impulse to
say oh here's a cute little
mathematician of this problem never I
can solve that math problem that will be
fun upon good paper and that leads back
to this question of art do we then
overstate our results as having solve
the problem but all I think the other
reason why we have this urge to say oh
we can fix it is that we feel that we're
caught up for better or worse like the
rest of society in this technological
moment which is deploying algorithms
everywhere whether or not they make any
sense or or will improve anything simply
because they're the newest latest thing
so we see we feel sort of swept lung by
this and if we can make any even
incremental improvement in the ships
direction then maybe we're doing a
little good but I agree with you that we
often think too much in terms of those
increments
purpose and that one of the things that
we can do is technical people to say
wait a second this whole direction needs
to be rethought the other thing I wanted
to say though in kind of a partial
defense of the paper the client very
blessed event
Nathan yes it is arrogant for them to
say we can decrease jail populations and
crime and we know how to do it and it's
going to be 24% on the other hand they
are in a quantitative way pointing out
that there isn't this zero-sum
relationship that politicians tell us
there is between incarceration on the
one hand and crime on the other and
that's a good thing and a part of the
subversive thing so anyway but I really
appreciated your yeah those are those
are all fair points which I would say
since you largely okay we're very kind
agree and I think you know on the the
moon Nathan at all paper I am why his
name stuck in my head and not the other
co-authors
I don't even necessarily disagree with
any of the policy prescriptions that
they make in the paper but I think the
and as I say it's a little bit of a
catch-22 I on the terms in which I want
to have the discussion I can't really
prove what I think is so pernicious
about the ways in which quantitative
knowledge claims have become incredibly
privileged in our society that anything
if you say you know Francis you know how
should you know what novels should we
teach to kids in school you know learn
music or art I mean this is a sort of
like the most cliched way to go to the
argument but it's still a true one
plenty of people in education schools
will say well what's the evidence that
you know that like learning how to play
the piano is good you know and like this
is a crazy question to me and I think
the the effects that unless you can come
up with you know if you don't say 24.8%
like no one takes you seriously right
like in policymaking circles and and I
think that's that's really really
problematic in a way that it's easy to
be blind to because you just go along
you're like well this is this is how the
games played and
we do it and then this is necessary and
it ends up I think just cheapening the
life of the mind in a way that I find
really really disturbing I was gonna say
something else to thank susunde and
Kevin and Robert then Patti I may say
one and then this perspective I think
there's a fundamental flaw when you have
a reductionist view or returning
important features of who we are into
numbers I agree
I also think that as a as a computer
scientist we can push back more from the
promise of AI and the reality and
there's a lot of Wizard of Oz style
projects where I can list several where
there's actually a human behind the
curtain rent providing the information
that you think is coming from this robot
and you think there's an untapped
psychology of why we trust these robots
and that I mean anyone who's in a
relationship that has like fought with
their partner over the directions the
map directions versus their own
knowledge understands that this is a
challenge for us and wide release about
these fights even different friends this
time to make that to give up power
and this has been happening since we've
had machines you know you look a classic
Mechanical Turk like why do we want to
believe this
maybe there's a further step in terms of
our underlying humanity that is missing
this some sort of construction yeah I
mean I think you're absolutely right I
think if I were more of a sort of like a
literary or critical theorist rather
than a journalist I would I would would
go down that line and say that there is
something of our sort of impulse towards
the divine u-matic the things we use to
attribute to spirits minor gods we now
want to give on machines that have the
sort of like prophetic values in a kind
of weird way my questions answer I was
wondering if you had thoughts about how
look the Machine discipline should
proceed because there's like an extreme
way through here talk right which is to
say something like well we should all
just like stop all that go back to their
good ol days but I mean you probably
don't mean that yeah I mean it's a good
question um and I don't have a good
answer but I have thought about it right
I mean some of my best friends are
computer scientists and I like what they
do and and I admire the intellectual
achievement behind it I think there's a
few different
sure the avenues that I've thought about
this question along one of them is that
the socio-economic consequences of
machine learning are completely opaque
to me I think you know there's an
argument that oh you know the Industrial
Revolution happened and before the
Industrial Revolution people were afraid
that the machines would take all the
jobs and we made new jobs like a lot
fewer people work in agriculture today
than did a hundred years ago but these
people do other things and and it's okay
and the standard of living has raised
productivity has gone up and we still
have live in a society that has lots of
problems but that a basic idea that most
people work except for people who are
unable to or these people who have
accumulated a great amount of wealth
which we can have differing sort of like
political views on how we deal with that
but that work in the way that it existed
you know in 500 BC still exists in a
roughly similar way today except we have
electricity and water and and all these
nice things not everybody on earth but
you know men many of us or there's a
view that this you know the moment we're
in now is fundamentally different from
the Industrial Revolution right and that
all the basic needs of humanity will be
met you know the all the truck driving
jobs are going to go away the
self-driving cars a lot of the
manufacturing jobs have already gone
away and that we're gonna have to sort
of in the next you know 20 to 50 years
fundamentally reshape our economic
relationships with one another because
of the intellectual achievements of
machine learning and I just I think you
know there's plenty of people who claim
that they can see this one way or the
other and I just can't right and I think
the answer to your question in part
depends on I think there are things that
are relying on algorithmic judgment in
many aspects
I think look I'm not blanket against it
right there there are cases in which it
can be useful it can lead towards equity
but I think there are many cases in
which it's bad regardless of whether or
not it works well but it's bad in
different ways if like oh you're like
this thing doesn't actually work and
then there are ways in which even and
this is a question of the sort of the
timescales and what you're looking at it
I was I read a very mediocre book about
the future of autonomous weapons a
couple of years ago and you know one of
the things that the sort of this wasn't
in the book but a thought experiment
that occurred to me it was saying about
how you know you haven't have autonomous
weapons on the battlefield and we have
you know they might make mistakes so we
want them to be judicious but in other
ways maybe they'll be because the
machine learning gets really good better
at recognizing an insurgent from a
shepherd or something and my thought
experiment was that say that you have
the the best the deepest learning
algorithm of all that makes infallible
judgments about it at an instantaneous
time slice about who is or is not an
insurgent of like it can see because it
also can you know do some neuroimaging
thing and see within people's minds and
you know this this this thing can can
say okay you hate America you do not
hate America you're just a shepherd you
know up in the Afghan mountains or
something mm yeah and you know I'm only
gonna kill the people who hate America
right and this is what the Pentagon
spends billions of dollars on it like as
an American like I don't feel great
about that system like even if it even
it we're making a you know quote-unquote
correct judgment in a given time slice
which is just to say that there are ways
in which algorithmic judgment even if
it's working like as well as designed is
still I think deeply problematic so I
mean should we look
the analogy with nuclear weapons is a
really bad one
and and biological and chemical weapons
it's kind of the only one that exists
and I don't think it's a very good one
but there are very strict regimes
against the proliferation of nuclear
weapons which don't work all that well
because at the end human knowledge is
hard to contain and spreads but there
was a sort of attempt on the part of the
bureaucracy of lots of countries to to
constrain this flow of knowledge which i
think was not has had limited success
I'm not even sure it was a good idea and
I don't think that it makes sense to
sort of treat knowledge about computer
science as a as a state secret I don't
know this is a very long word this is
something I struggle with which is
apparent in my struggling to give you a
good answer I think that the very short
version and then we'll move on is that I
think attention has to be paid to the
business structures within which all of
this exists I think there's something
very different about knowledge that is
in Google or Facebook or Amazon and
knowledge that is at the University of
California at Berkeley so I think
there's I don't know that this is a
sufficient step but I think a necessary
step is like looking at the the nature
of monopolistic tech technology
companies at least as a first step in
thinking of how this knowledge affects
yeah it's actually so he thinks
discussed since then but we may be
talking length of an industrial guru
later I had I mean to comment slash
questions relating to your criticism
which i think is very valid but just
overstating with results of that if you
start convincing yourself missing
everything
and you also do what I said I think that
journalists are playing very strong role
in not only journalists but like news
offices in
but I think that taking step back with
two comes from you say what is it's
important I think to distinguish and
Chris way you think about this between
the research itself and the way it's old
because the research itself I think
could also frequently be misleading
where we we simplify the model
introversion we simplifying the model is
good but sometimes we simplifying it to
the point that that we kind of over
fitness indicate business vacation
because we want to draw a certain
conclusion and so we we search for the
simplification that gives us the
conclusion we want in and I see this
quite a bit actually also in looking at
fairness yeah in there I think there's a
real problem of the research itself the
other type of situation it's a thing a
bit more related to what though was much
media there's research that actually has
a very important point to say but the
way it's presented and especially the
way it's presented after like several
iterations of quoting getting there a
journalist survivor people over sells it
by a lot and and neglects both the fact
that just a model it's just assimilation
and it shouldn't only be taking it as an
indication maybe something is happening
and so I think it's a warning as soon as
you know some things they like to your
comments but then which one are you
maybe more worried about the the second
thing is that I think the situation if
you do describing the focus on results
exhibited exist in many fields and I see
it or in the computer science and other
programming there's a deep learning
workshop and many situation many papers
there also I feel are completely over
selling what what is it it's not so bad
because the people reading it it's also
bad but it that's so bad because people
are reading it in our technical people
and hopefully you can actually like see
through them and they didn't here the
problem is that these technical papers
are being oversold maybe the same way
but then the they're being raised by
non-technical people who don't have the
tools to kind of understand this over
selling and who don't apply the proper
deflationary
yeah I mean it gets a give me a vicious
cycle I mean I think to your first point
there's a dilemma right I'm like much
more willing to cut slack to people who
are doing research because they're just
trying to get an understanding of
something but not actually trying to
sort of implement policy or make the
decisions based on that right they're
like oh I'm writing a paper and like
here's what I think but then there's a
okay well what's the point of doing that
unless you're actually going to act on
that knowledge but it's this that you
know if you're looking at I mean there's
like this that beautiful example
yesterday of was it in Colombia I think
with the the means-tested Assistance
Program with like this discontinuity
that got introduced into into this into
this you know this was this nicely
shaped bell curve and then all of a
sudden there's this discontinuity and
you don't like if you were just like an
economist like trying to like look at
you know what that and I forget what
exactly it was being measured but some
index index of poverty right now how
that was constructed if you're just
measuring this because you're like okay
I want to understand like how severe the
problem of poverty is and I'm not going
to do anything base directly on this
measure I mean this I'm not this is not
my insight rise is a well-known
phenomenon then you can do that and and
it works reasonably well and then you
say okay but now we're going to make an
intervention based on exactly this
measure and then all of a sudden the
measure stops being useful and that's
the dilemma right because like why if
you're not gonna try and do something
based on your measure like why bother
doing it to begin with so it's like it's
perfectly reasonable as to have your
research matter to say like okay I've
learned this thing now I want to do
something about it and then all of a
sudden your data source becomes suspect
and and that's and I think the fact that
that is a systemic consequence of
depending on data is I mean like that
that other very very good example about
you know what to do about cash bail and
just say okay let's not try and do a
detailed regression of the consequences
to say like look it's fundamentally
unjust to
have pretrial detention four people for
nonviolent offenses let's just get rid
of cash bail for nonviolent offenses
right without doing some analysis of the
data but just relying on a principle and
I think that's part of my argument about
why data is not as conclusive or
reliable as it might appear to be
because this you know that discontinuity
in the bell curve was not like okay this
is and I know that there was a tweak to
try and get better at this and I'm not
the right person to sort of like speak
at a technical level of like whether you
know moving towards the Nash equilibria
to the left of the curve is the right
thing to do
maybe it is but I think to the extent
that we can reason about first
principles about I mean that basically
social systems are not physical systems
right and I think so much of this is
applying a mathematical methodology that
came out of physics and applied
mathematics to social systems and and
and it's a it's a category error
mathematics is logic and if you do it
right the fold is between our
assumptions in our modeling but not in
the way we go to conclusions nothing the
mathematics itself right but that logic
applied to physical systems had great
success right our belief in the power of
mathematics I'm not right but we came to
a belief that those models were good
because of their efficacy in the
physical world I agree with them I think
they're most
so I think a good number new teeth fall
under just generally like the critiques
of automation in general as well which
is its only problem I think do you have
a computer scientist my fault mom said
you know we shouldn't automate
everything because like why should only
the blue-collar workers go to their jobs
[Music]
and this brings me to my second point
that how we talk about politics in this
field and I guess so okay so the
automation is bad or maybe the person
replaces it's also bad because it makes
it more opaque or less transparent for
many people it's making judgments about
but from my point of view is less about
transparency it's not like oh I wish I
knew how the system works then I could
you know easy it's more especially
across different demographics they they
distrust the system is it distrust the
judge this officer like and how the
human decision would be so it's no good
that you speed it up can you automate it
right so then I guess I guess what I
want to my critique for this bill that
would be that all this whole field is
saying every time you try to come up
with the tech solution for a social
problem it messes up and the danger of
this field is that we are a tech
solution
and I guess when I hear these talks that
are more centered on that might forget
exactly like what are we trying to do
like what because when I hear talk about
ok we're getting this accuracy for this
type of fairness there are some cases
like I could think of both cases I'm
like oh I submit my algorithm or there
or another case of life what if you
applied just everything you need to
recidivism that'd be horrible don't do
that and I think we do have some
humorous in device defining these
mathematical concepts abstracted away
from the context and I guess it's just
been a very different workshop this week
than it was definitely and I don't think
we've really reckon there wrestled with
the fact how different the language the
conversations and just the demographic
is and why you're changing just
demographics has changed so much the
types of conversation we're having about
the politics about it if we're talking
about
you know like how you can do this how
should we punish people in the last
workshops every wall stop or what do you
mean how do we punish people we don't
punitive
punitive systems are worse than
restorative ones they just don't work so
like I think sometimes we jump into
these things without asking
without questioning the prints of what
we're even trying to solve and my
question to his field and he's like what
are we even what are we even trying to
accomplish so I'll be jumping into it
because for more math that's funny
or we actually trying to solve the you
know weighted compass or something that
was a whistle blowing thing why are we
trying to create better algorithms for
them because the people that originally
whistle do it would maybe say okay this
is better evidence to start questioning
in politics behind community control so
I guess I agree with your statements
about my patient but I feel like the
bigger question is what is the role of
this field is it to like we can use our
tools very well for missile mode and I'm
not seeing so far how we can use our
tool is to have an abstract model that
what we're do you mean by whistle blow
to find places where algorithms are
doing formidable things and we have the
tools to say that in a concrete way and
expose it but then we have this this
knee-jerk reaction to say okay let's fix
it and I think we try to fix it in a
political way and I feel like that's
doing a failure like do we become part
of it
another text eviction - that's my
critique but I also like you hey I think
I agree with the bulk if not all of that
sentiment basically I mean it's a it's a
complex set of questions and I think
part of this sort of perennial appeal of
technology for as long as it's existed
is that it offers a you know pain-free
solution but like oh we don't have to
have a contentious political process
because this thing will make it better
and you know there are times I mean I
don't want my sort of think about it for
myself not not for you but might sort of
like temperamental unease with a lot of
the ways in which technology is both the
discourse around technology and
technology itself today to forget that
like antibiotics are great and like so
is having light and so is like not
having to like Trek to the well for
clean water like it's I mean this is
these are obvious statements but they're
also easy to forget and that's what like
that that potential for technology to
improve the lives of people like is not
like like there's like jerks at Davos
who go around saying this I'm like I
hate those guys I'm like hey this is
dumb but like actually like technology
has improved the lives of people a great
deal and I think that lack of social
trust that you mentioned is real and
it's for good cause and how as a society
to work our way out of that I mean we
haven't talked much about I mean it's
not like a conference about politics
right he put like the President of the
United States that like I don't know
probably not many people in this room
voted for him right and nevertheless
he's he's the president and this is like
a profoundly screwed up time in the
politics of the country and it's like
insane to have these technocratic
discussions and not consider it and yet
like I certainly don't pretend to have a
way out other than like platitudes about
optimism about it being which you know
like I mean we can all try and we should
to be kind to one another and think
about it but how and I think you know
some of these you know as I've maybe
more personal but like as I've grown
older I'm just done less and less of an
optimistic about the future and about
the you know inequity has always existed
in in human history and maybe always
will and that sort of technocratic
promise to transcend that I think is
false and can often make things worse
rather than better so there was another
question sorry it's like I I think a lot
of your critique was automation and
algorithms in general which I think a
lot of people understand to some degree
especially people working on this that
you know a lot of these models don't
actually work they don't live up to the
promise of what they're meant to do they
establish really messed up behaviors and
the users and things like that and I
think that's why the general critique
about algorithms but I think the
fairness community is focused on the
problem of having these algorithms that
are already you know in many cases
already deployed that decision being
made
a completely separate party
disproportionately affecting different
populations and I think that's at least
my impression of what this community
really cares about is that disparate
impact and I think that is a word the
sort of cause and something to take very
seriously even in the case of algorithm
sort of you know being presented as you
know mechanisms to find criminals you
know that should work for you think you
can debate sort of the politics around
why that algorithm the design of that
algorithm might be problematic but you
know if you're saying that this is going
to benefit a community in a particular
way that should work if it's a black
community or an Asian community or a
white community and that disparate
impact shouldn't you know it should if
you if you say your model works it
should actually work for everyone in
their beverage for you to say that it
works and I think that's what the third
is I this is a sizable group of this
fairness community is like focused on
and interested in is that question of
you know for saying these models work do
they actually work for the full scope of
the population that were you know that
these models are actually serving and I
think like you can make a lot of
critique like a lot of important
comments about you know should we deploy
these models are the poles of these
models well design is the bottom wall
design and I think those are very
important questions I agree with that
um I'm just not sure if that's a
critique of the fairness community I
think that's like a general ethics
question and a general like you know
automation question and not to say that
like we should work on it I think there
should be many people thinking about
that and working on it but it's sort of
like given the fact that you have a
deployed system you know that's making a
particular cleaning house valid is that
clean for these different populations
and
to me how do we do a better job sort of
qualifying these claims for these
different groups of people that exist
that you're you know that you're
deploying this model on so I think that
that is a that is for me but one of the
big questions that this community
addresses so I'm not sure what you think
about that goal of you know looking at
these different populations and try to
reconcile the sort of how these models
perform across these different groups
and that being sort of a valid or worthy
objective or focus for the community to
think about so what I think it's a very
good point and thank you for it I think
clarify the critique I'm trying to make
but you might visit really I think that
is a noble and worthy short-term goal
that may actually make problems worse
over the long term is that I think to
give it like a very potted history of
the sort of intellectual reception of
algorithmic automation in like what I
consider the like center left of
American discourse in like university
departments in the page of New York
Times listening to NPR I think okay
which is not the totality of the
political universe by any stretch but
it's it's an influential and substantial
part of how the you know 300 million
people in this country talk about
technology and I think you know 10 years
ago 15 years ago you know Google's IPO
that you know there was a these things
are great like look the internet like
you know the Internet's going to bring
look at the Arab Spring the Internet's
bringing democracy like we're you know
and you have all the Charlatans of seven
different stripes getting up there
proclaiming some sort of Tilos to human
suffering and then I think in the last
couple of years there's been a real like
this I think the the sort of like
fairness community although that's a
sort of like vague analytic construct
has been very influential and there's
been like a real backlash that says like
hey wait like let's look at the criminal
justice system there are all of these
ways in which algorithms are
disproportionately
impacting for the worse the
disadvantaged in our society minority
groups and so those critiques of like
are they're absolutely right right and I
agree with them and they're serious
problems but that I think it's much more
difficult to enunciate the ways in which
algorithms can have a sort of like
universal effect on how we think of
ourselves as human beings like because
you can point the the pernicious effects
of algorithmic judgment on minorities
are very concrete material effects often
right you can point and say like here's
this like thing that happened not some
like mental like how do I feel about
myself but a like I'm getting sent to
not getting a job that I should get for
instance right and that's a concrete
like that's an injustice we can point to
it we can understand it and then say and
I think you were making this point
before that okay let's let's fix these
problems and then we can go back to
being like enthusiastic and triumphalist
about algorithms and that's where I
think because it's so much simpler to
talk about the disparate effects that
algorithms have on either subgroups or
this you know there's notion of
individual fairness that Cynthia put
forth with you know some co-authors a
few years ago and if I'm getting the
intellectual history of that wrong
forgive me it's so much easier to point
to that that we don't then struggle with
the ways in which reliance on algorithms
shape society that should all all all of
our relationships with one another
so that's does that make sense are you
saying that by focusing on the
difference of performance between
different subgroups for example or
individuals
it looks like purposive almost of like
the way that it's going to actually not
okay to deploy an operator on a
particular context that way yes so kind
of owning out of time this is very
interesting conversation if it'll only
take four more questions I'll try to my
in the beginning the Big Bang Yona def
high e and sorry what's your name : I'm
gonna end this oh well that's the last
four questions but feel free to stay in
top yeah not going anywhere no I mean
eventually they'll kick me out put it so
I think one thing that I've a lot of
people do and it's an understandable
concern is like what we think of as the
fairness community is inherently like an
interdisciplinary project right and we
don't necessarily think of it it's not
anymore because we like kind of all
publish maybe in like the same venue
like that star great for you know
whatever but but to like a large extent
I find that like the critique of like
like people are being mathematicians or
computer scientists and are like
narrowing down the world into like a
very simplified model and then making
statements about that model and like
those statements obviously cannot
generalize right um to be like kind of
claiming that the computer scientists
and mathematicians should be doing the
job that that like they didn't think
that they were maybe doing ahead of time
um and like I mean you can really
reasonably ask yourself look who is
responsible for doing that kind of work
right and I think that maybe we should
be and maybe we aspire to but like there
are a whole bunch of other communities
who do really important work like
exactly on that line and I usually think
of like the the type of people who are
presenting here earlier as being people
who like to sort of collaborate with
those people but who are not themselves
the ones advising policy
and so I wonder whether you see the same
distinction or whether you think that
like we have already been put into this
role whether we like it or not you
should I'm not sure I guess I fully
follow I mean
I'll save this and I mean there's people
come from any number of disciplines to
study similar questions right they come
and group the Social Sciences together
right like sociologists historians
social anthropologists economists all
come from distinct intellectual
traditions as do mathematicians and
computer scientists and I think you know
speaking of this sort of like the way in
which sort of like trendiness in
academia and the desire to be noticed
and published and get tenure and so
forth like I think it's we've had a
vogue at least for the last since World
War two and maybe longer of
interdisciplinarity right like and then
like you know computer science didn't
exist as a discipline a hundred years
ago and like now it does so like you
know one do disciplines sort of like
crystallize and and form
I don't know the in I promise to be not
long-winded and I'm a liar so we can
talk about it more I guess after I mean
I think in short everybody has a
responsibility to try and like not over
check that impulse to to oversell their
results but and there's something to be
said for you know if you have like I
have nothing against mathematical
economics or pure math as you know
recognized as such of like I don't know
equilibrium like these this is like a
very interesting mathematical result as
a mathematical model and recognizing the
limits of mathematical models as such
like doesn't mean that this isn't can't
be like a rich intellectual discipline
for thinking about the world with a
humility for how those models are
applied that's probably not a very
satisfactory answer
I really like the discussion but I do
want to like mention mica point so okay
I don't know who is a very like famous
STRs area and he wants that he has this
theory that if we look back into human
history like for any technology Alfred
and why it was created it was created by
scientists and mathematicians finish and
like people just like the goal is just
to demonstrate the potential of the
technology without worrying about the
actual impact why it's actually deployed
in the real world but then when the
technology becomes popular and then when
it accurate be used and then people
realize there are a lot of problems and
that people come and they like Anna fix
these problems so this happens to every
technology so I guess nowadays it's just
that it's a it's just right now we are
at the stage that we have like that this
machine learning English like AI
technology algorithms automation like
very nice stage that oh it starts to be
deployed in everyday services and now we
see the problem so like we are coming to
fix it so I guess this is just like if
we're looking back in history it's just
it's kind of not like nothing ready to
get to me I feel like I'm less worried
about this but I feel like if we like
believe in history like it's like we
will find out like the solutions to
always to like improve these
technologies and to make it like it
usable and like it already right he like
integrates our social value and societal
value into the systems and potentially
and make it like better but that's my
plea but I guess another thing I've I
could relate to your comment story
today yo yo yo yo yo comment so it's
like um I stick to addressing this
province it requires like efforts from
multiple disciplines it's not just a
mathematician so put on for me brush the
eye we're never thinking just about like
trying to abstract a problem and then I
do the like just sauce sauce this mask
over we we use we call the human Center
design so it's like a design method like
you're trying to pick this province and
so first need to understand human needs
info like before we even start thinking
about the possible solutions so these
are the I guess like also social
psychologists or like those people from
other like them yeah I guess every
disciplines that have to have like
missiles they have to like you and I did
and they are all like useful to address
these problems so um I believe that like
so I guess I'm probably more optimistic
so things like yeah it's still possible
to like address things some like issues
like we see and I guess finally things
like that nothing is really perfect so
if there is something like in a design
or all the kinds but oh it's not
searching for perfection the goal is to
achieve progress and improvement so we
want to like improve not to say that we
want to have like a perfect solution so
briefly I mean you're not wrong to make
this analogy to history but at the same
time you can look up advertisements for
plastics from the 1950s and these like
babies wrapped in plastic and they're
like plastic it's amazing and like now
we have tons of plastic in the oceans
and it's a severe environmental problem
or you can look at advertisements for
DDT when it was first invented and like
this things terrific and then like it
turns out it gave lots of people cancer
so I mean you're right that novel
technologies become widely adopted when
they're perceived to have utility and
then only later do we have a reckoning
with the influence of those technologies
but the fact that this isn't the first
in history that we've had to struggle
like is not instructive that like the
struggle doesn't have to be had and that
like oh this is like a normal thing in
the course of human history and like
let's not worry about it so much right
like it's not the first time but it's
still it's still like something to be to
be worked out I think to your other
point I think it's a little too
charitable to just say like oh every
discipline has its contribution like I
think social psychology makes knowledge
claims based on you know quantitative
studies of like what you know 40 college
students who are getting paid 8 bucks
each like think and then says this is
how human nature is and like I think
it's [ __ ] like you know and maybe
I'm wrong but like that's what I think
first workshop unless reflecting on some
of the differences in the discussion and
I think a lot of what you identify the
quantification bias the preference for
numbers that the only form of empirical
data we can recognize is quantitative
data and not qualitative data the
substitution of models for reality the
critique of the rationalism actor that
underlies most of mainstream economic
theory the critique of methodological
individualism are old old debates and
the social sciences and the humanities
and I think some of us in the room of a
particular generation would remembers
those argument on the two cultures where
the model of knowledge was a classical
model it was a humanistic model and
science at that point just after the
Second World War had not established
itself as a truth-telling form of
narrative that should be trusted and
believed in and the current moment we've
really flipped it but I I guess I'm
wondering as a journalist since these
debates are old and you're you're
marking them and you're also working
with a group of who are self reflexive
very articulate about what the norms of
the community are can describe the the
community
it's a well-intentioned community
because it wants to combat bias and
discrimination how as a journalist would
you actually write in such a way that
the discussion moves away from a kind of
two cultures into a way that would bring
those of us together the first workshop
was lawyers and social scientists and
computer science and mathematicians and
this this group is not totally
homogeneous but more homogeneous than
say listen the first gathering so do you
have any preliminary shot thoughts that
you would share about why you would
write about your experiences sitting on
these workshops um so I mean to your
first point you're right that these are
old debates I mean I think their debates
like you look at the
freakanomics podcast or something right
like I think they're debates in which
the right side lost and in the public
discourse so I'm certainly not claiming
to be making sort of like novel
critiques like you're right that they've
they've been around for a long time but
I think I think
the same way that others like debates
about you know more philosophy and been
around for longer and like we still have
them in terms of how to write about it
you know I mean as best I can
I don't that's not like I've already
satisfactory answer but I think you know
those same pressures that exist to have
succinct noteworthy results for to get
you know published in a journal with a
high impact factor you know exist in the
world of journalism as well in a similar
if not worse fashion and it's something
that I mean it just means like fighting
it out in the trenches of trying to
figure out like how you know the easiest
story to sell for me is person makes
discovery not team of people makes
discovery right but like what could
that's too complicated who did what one
person you know yesterday in her lab dr.
X realized why which is important cover
of the magazine easiest thing right
that's not how the world works right so
then how to you know convey some of
these struggles in writing it's it's
hard I don't think I'm very good at it I
do the best that I can and some of it is
sometimes finding particular people and
how they evolve over time relying on
other people's arguments I have another
friend who's a journalist who describes
himself as a since his coin is not mine
although I agree with it a sort of
bridger of social distance like trying
to come up and say okay here here's what
one person has to say that might be
within a community but other people
don't read it in trying to sort of like
translate that and explain it and give
it context but you know I don't have
last question yeah so I wanted to offer
a sort of a very brief but like
optimistic response which is that you
you pointed out that you know the public
discourse has already been somewhat
shifted but I would say it by the work
in this field to point out issues of
disparate impact which in these publicly
deployed algorithms right in here I'm
obviously referring to the work by
ProPublica but also by others like I
like miss love this talk we saw the
other day to really try to audit these
algorithms and make these issues
apparent and you know I hear you saying
that you feel like that doesn't go far
enough right and the sort of optimistic
response that I would answer to that is
that you know I think that already in a
very short amount of time we've shifted
the public discourse a large way and
that the types of critiques that you're
bringing up are already being brought up
within about to our community and we're
you know for example published at last
year's conference and we're a big topic
of conversation and so you know I see
that as being one of the largest impacts
of this community you know has already
had and can continue to have right and I
think that part of what allows us to
shift the public discourse in that way
is having rigorous foundation for a lot
of those critiques and also in making
those critiques in an interdisciplinary
way it sounds like a great note to close
on home so this is like a much kinder
reception than I expected from everybody
and it's been super fun for me at least
and thanks for
[Applause]
those optimistic or pessimistic and I
really appreciate all your criticism and
hope we take your default into account
in our long-term research agenda it's a
small thing everybody for coming and
especially to those who get talked I
also want to thank the other two
co-organizers fall on their way to SFO
this interesting conversation